Pamela story archetypes and the
qualities that these archetypes must
possess what I work with is a system
that is in the deeper and more advanced
spiritual teachings which if you're
studying the mystery schools or you get
deeper into Buddhism or mystic
Christianity or mystic Islam you find
this five a group of five are two paths
and it's the warrior the monk or the
ascetic the scientists the magician and
the lover these paths are the way that
you approach life and how you react to
life and all of the wonderful archetypes
that people use they can come under any
of those are capaz so you can have the
mother warrior you know the mother lover
you can have the martyr monk which is
pretty typical you know somebody on that
priestly line oh you can you have the
martyr scientist you know someone who's
it made this wonderful invention and
nobody believes them and they go to
great lengths in order to prove what
they do
so the archetypes can fall under any of
these five are Copaxone there are three
levels for each arca path just as there
are in many initiative systems whether
it's masonry or a lot of the the mystery
schools even our educational system
you've got usually three things you've
got grade school middle school high
school and then you go on course to your
further education but the first level
for the arca pass is that entry level
it's the soldier it's the nun it's the
student who is going to become the
scientist
it's the Sorcerer's Apprentice and in
love I think what's so interesting is
the first level of the lover is the fan
the person who is alone they're not with
the beloved or the one they want but
it's this yearning towards and then the
second level up
those who have got it pretty much under
control then you've got the warrior
you've got the priestess you have the
scientist and you have the magician and
you have someone in a wonderful loving
relationship so there's two now in the
lovers then the third level is where you
start to get a bit more abstract and
most most of your characters are going
to be on those first two levels of the
arca pass and making their character
arcs from one to another or crossing
paths because at the very highest you've
got the The Regent in the warrior path
so you've got the Empress or the king
that height and they're their influence
is huge where is it that first level
you're just a soldier you don't have
much influence at all so it's about you
know going up that that scale of
influence and how they will affect other
characters and then on the priestly line
you've got high priests High Priestess
and the scientist you have the
Philosopher's yeah I thought that was
interesting when I first learned about
that but it makes sense you know someone
who studies the world and studies people
and studies the cosmos you've got to be
thinking of why and what's it all for
and what is our part here so the
scientist who becomes the philosopher
then that's the the pinnacle of that
particular path and you see it a lot in
oh let's say that the series cosmos
whether it was Carl Sagan or the new one
with Neil deGrasse Tyson right there
philosophizing as well as presenting the
science the magician of course it's the
Magus you know it's Gandalf the White
and Saruman on the dark side and then
for the lover it's the one who has
united with spirituality they may be
physically alone again but they are
connected so much to the higher self the
higher spiritual realm because all of
these are said to be paths towards
enlightenment
ultimately although a lot of times when
you're in the lower aspects of it you
don't know you're just doing your thing
and trying to become well sometimes a
better priestess sometimes you just want
to learn the science to take advantage
of things so you can get dark and light
on any of those but by using those five
are capaz then we have character
profiles for each of them that give the
strengths and the weaknesses the hopes
the fears styles of speaking styles of
acting so you can tweak your dialogue
then if it's a long someone on them the
warrior path they're going to speak
differently they will say the same thing
but in a different way with different
words so it's a wonderful tool that
doesn't get so complex as all the
different archetypes and there's some
good working out there and some good
books with the archetypes but I find
it's much it's much easier to work with
the arca pass and then plug your
archetypes in to that if you want or
they're also archetypes but they are the
arca paths and those character profiles
then compliment the steps up and down
and you've got a really good possibility
for drama you know with you you've got
the priest over here and the scientist
over here while that conflicts been
going on for ever and you know the lover
and the warrior so it's it's really a
wonderful way to use archetypes in
creating story characters and dramatic
conflict
you